because empathy is so important to a
great interview let's ask the most
challenging version of empathy which is
when you're sitting across
from a man on the brink of war that
that leads to tens of millions of deaths
which is hitler so if you could
interview hitler in 1939
as the drums of war start to beat or
1941 when they're already
full on war but there's still a lot of
pacifists there's still a lot of people
yeah unsure what are the motivations
behind um what hitler is doing
how would you do that interview what
depends when you do it if you do it in
38
no i certainly would have
no you have to
if you sit down across from hitler you
empathize what is your beef what are you
what where have you been what is your
consciousness
why do you hate uh jewish people why why
uh
what is you know all these questions
that come up
his sense of grievance as a result of
world war one there's justifications
there etc but if i and
by the way churchill was trying to make
a deal with him in 38.
that's a fact that people don't know is
churchill himself and you know there was
still the desire in england to make
peace with germany uh
and it was seen as a possible
what hit what churchill really wanted
was hitler to go against russia and he
he
anything to destroy the bolsheviks so he
was using hitler as much as he could to
go after russia
but
hitler was too elusive to get to pin him
down
but if you remember hitler was very kind
at the end of kind is not the right word
was
did not go after the british empire when
he had france and he could have
he had another objective which was
obviously the east
so uh hitler's goal
i think
he always had an admiration for england
it's interesting story always
and the the empire
yes
and certainly church we have no doubts
now from history revisionism that
churchill's interest main interest was
not germany it was the british empire
yes and to preserve it to india the road
to india and all that and middle east
churchill fought the entire uh war with
the concept of preserving the british
empire all his goals he sent america on
a goose chase into italy
you could argue instead of establishing
a sincere second front in western europe
uh
interesting man uh so i would have tried
to get you know i think i would approach
it the same way in 1939 it would have
been a different story because at that
point
he'd attacked poland and uh in 1940
france so there's it's another ball game
but certainly if whatever at whatever
point you talk to him you i would try to
understand his point so i would i'm not
judging you hitler i'm saying to you
tell me what you're thinking why are you
invading russia what's your thought
that's all an interviewer should do he
shouldn't be
expressing his contempt for hitler which
like an american journalist interviewing
putin it's i'm getting brownie points
for for expressing my contempt yeah for
you that that does i don't that doesn't
wash with me that's ugly
you